c'est officiel nelson mandela a gagné
les premières élections multiraciales de
l'histoire sud africaine avec 62,6 % des
voix frederik de klerk et son parti sont
arrivés en deuxième position avec plus
de 20% des voix
ce scrutin était considéré comme libre
et équitable
rejoignant en afrique du sud nos envoyés
spéciaux bernard lebrun et alain st à
l'extrême pointe de l'afrique
le port du cap et à 45 minutes de
navigation sur le bateau de
l'administration pénitentiaire encore
plus loin encore plus bas détaché du
continent
lille du bagne de robben island entre
les deux une mer infestée de requins qui
rend impossible toute tentative
d'évasion population de l'île 235
gardien tous militaires 700 prisonniers
et 300 habitants
robben island son nom est entré dans
l'histoire et attire désormais de très
nombreux touristes à cause de celui que
l'on a appelé le prisonnier politique le
plus célèbre du monde nelson mandela a
franchi cette porte le 12 juin 1964 et
n'a recouvré la liberté que 27 années
plus tard dans ces cellules au toit de
tôle surchauffée il n'y a plus
assure-t-on de prisonniers politiques
uniquement des droits communs
interdiction de les filmer
interdiction de pénétrer la cellule du
bagnard devenu chef d'état ne se visite
pas pour l'instant pas même une carte
postale qui ne la montre il faudra
attendre le transfert de la prison qui
est envisagée le bagne deviendra un
véritable musée grévin
après date d'ouverture l'an 2004 si le
cap est elle une ville olympique
on visitera alors le cimetière des
prisonniers vieux de trois siècles
l'inhospitalité de lille a profité à la
nature pingouins cormorans se sont
multipliées par milliers ils seront
bientôt chez eux sur cette île du bout
du monde nelson mandela a passé 18
années de sa vie il y à prier travail et
préparer son retour en politique il ya
surtout appris le prix très élevé de la
liberté